One method to get from A to B across a vast body of water is known as dead reckoning.
So what's dead reckoning. In dead reckoning, we start with a known location--city A.
Then we're going to keep track of our ship's heading and its speed to determine
where in this route from A to B we might actually B located.
So for example, let's say our ship's started off moving for 1 hour east at a speed of 10 km/h.
Well, east is this way and 10 km/h for 1 hour means I've moved 10 km,
and I can follow this sort of thinking as long as I keep good track of duration, heading and speed.
So 2 hours at southeast at 8 km/h but by 1 hour south at 5--so you get a feel for where you are
just by using this sort of dead reckoning method.
Of course, this method has some problems.
For example, how do you know the speed of your boat.